sie haben sicher gemerkt auch in dieser
Woche gehen Sie weiter die Demos gegen
Rechtsextremismus morgen z.B in Berlin
unter dem Motto wir sind die Brandmauer
derweil reagiert die AFD wie immer wie
man es erwarten durfte also mit leugnen
ablenken und natürlich mit rumheulen ne
war klar man man gibt halt das Opfer
dabei hat sich jetzt rausgestellt dass
die Verbindung der AFD zum von Korrektiv
aufgedeckten potsdammer Geheimtreffen
noch enger sind als gedacht
einer der Referenten hatte sogar einen
Job beim AFD Bundesvorstand und wurde
wohl aus dem Persönlichen Budget von
alisweideel bezahlt klar für die rechte
Gegenöffentlichkeit wird eine ganz
andere Wahrheit verbreitet das sind DDR
Methoden von Seiten dieses dubiosen
korrektivorgans mit Stasi ähnlichen
Geheimdienst und
zersetzungsmethoden das erinnert an die
dunkelsten Zeiten unserer
Geschichte
ach ja dieses weinerliche ich find es
fast ein bisschen undeutsch muss ich
sagen so die AFD bleibt natürlich dabei
die Demos gegen Rechts sind Fake von der
Ampel herbeigekarte komparen man lacht
erst aber tatsächlich wenn man sich die
Bilder genau anguckt dann sieht man hier
wie Robert habbeck mit seiner
fahrradrickcher persönlich jeden
antifahrkaaoten zur Demo fährt SAS
bewirken die Demonstrationen Thüringen
ist gerade bei einer Landratswahl der
AFD Kandidat gescheitert weil
offensichtlich ein paar Nichtwähler doch
mal aufgewacht sind allerdings war das
Ergebnis sehr sehr knapp und natürlich
kann das alles wenn es blöd läuft auch
AFD Anhänger mobilisieren Menschen die
es nicht mal schockiert wenn Ali Weidel
wie gerade in einem Interview mit einem
deutschen euaustritt
kcketiert also verstehen sie mit dem mit
dem ökonomischen
Selbstmord tolle Patrioten und doch man
fühlt sich chronisch missverstanden und
natürlich bösartig geframed ein linkes
man so schön sagt framing was seit
Jahren betrieben wird dass rechts was
völlig inakzeptaabes in Deutschland wäre
dabei ist der Begriff rechts ja positiv
besetzt mit Recht haben Rechtsstaat
Rechtsanwalt rechts vor links das sind
also alles Begriffe die eigentlich
positiv sind genau oder
Unrechtsregime äh Rechthaber äh
brechtdurchfall ja er hat Recht bzw gar
nicht so aus ihrer Sicht aus ihrer
kruden Sicht verteidigt die AFD im
Grunde unsere Demokratie so
argumentieren die also außer natürlich
wenn sie unter sich sind wenn die Tür zu
ist und irgendein Dödel vergisst das
Kameras laufen wenn wir morgen
Regierungsverantwortung haben dann muss
ein Großteil von den Leuten die hier
sind wieder nach Hause wenn wir morgen
in einer Regierungsverantwortung sind
dann müssen wir diesen Partei
abschaffen mein Gott was ist blo aus K
mit dem Frosch geworden meine Damen und
Herren Parteienstaat abschaffen Applaus
Applaus Applaus ja und das sagt ein
Landtagsabgeordneter der AFD aber gut
Schnappatmung bringt leider wenig die
anderen Parteien müssten z.B stattdessen
eigene Themen nach vorne schieben es ist
für mich absolut erbärmlich wie
erfolgreicht die AFD hier immer noch den
Diskurs bestimmt trotz allem neuestes
Beispiel wenn sie drauf achten
Entwicklungshilfe angreifen hört man
gerade überall Tenor alles nur Geld für
Quatsch woanders statt für anständige
Deutsche hier bei uns das ist zu Ende
gedacht inhuman und übrigens regelrecht
blöd während Putin und China sich immer
mehr Einfluss im globalen Süden kaufen
warum machen da so viele Politiker mit
und eben nicht nur von der AFD da muss
aber mal dringend nachgeschult
werden ne Stunde Nachsitzen bei Herrn
Hassknecht heute
Entwicklungshilfe so welchen
Schulversager haben wir denn heute
wieder auch ne bitte nicht der
ubert haben sie dich schon wieder mit
Flugblättern im Schulklo erwischt ach so
nee diesmal hat der absichtlich Fake
News über Radwege in Peru verbreitet
erstens der Radweg in Peru hat mit der
ompel wie du sie nennst nichts zu tun
den hat damals noch Gert Müller von der
CSU bewilligt kennt CSU kennst du
richtig dein Koalitionspartner die
bucklige Schwester der CDU zweitens du
Rechen Genie der deutsche Beitrag zum
Radweg beträgt genau 44 Millionen Euro
ich sag's noch mal langsam für DOF
44 ich will gar nicht auf die Radwege in
Peru eingehen für die hunderte Millionen
Euro aus Deutschland bezahlt werden
einadweg für 315 Millionen EUR über 400
Milliarden 400 Millionen für Radwege in
Peru aber ihre Kollegen könnten es doch
auch kritisieren und die richtigen
Zahlen nennen das macht ja aber die
Situation nicht besser ob das jetzt 315
oder 400 Millionen Sinn es sind weder
315 noch 400 es sind
44 du verstrahltes AFD
Backenhörnchen das sind die Leute Hubert
deren Bullshit du
nachplapperst natürlich kann man über
einzelne Projekte streiten
gendertraining in China z.B ob das jetzt
den uigur innen hilft na ja aber an sich
ist Entwicklungshilfe natürlich wichtig
auch aus Eigennutz wir sind eine
Exportnation vor allem aber hör endlich
auf dir Applaus mit Lügen zu
mich würde mal interessieren ob ein
solcher Radweg jemals gebaut wird oder
ob er nur eröffnet wird und nach der
nächsten Kurve endet und die Leute vor
Ort die Gelder anderweitig umlenken mich
würde es nicht wundern genau das sind
Peruaner die haben das Geld geklaut und
für pnflöten und Kokain ausgegeben der
Radweg wurde übrigens gerade in Lima
feierlich eröffnet und ist 200 Meilen
lang aber Lima gibt's wahrscheinlich
auch gar nicht ne bert wie ich dich
kenne bist du doch garantiert ein
limaaleugnerpi wegen Klima Lima ach komm
hat doch keinen Zweck mit dir deine
Mutter kann dich abholen nein weiß du
was du fährst heute zur Strafe mit dem
Fahrrad nach Hause und zwar ohne
Stützräder so wen haben wir noch oh nein
der schlimmste
adhsptient von allen Kuss du schreibst
jetzt einfach hundert Mal an die Tafel
ich will nie wieder mit Hubert regieren
wenn was ist ich bin wie immer im
Lehrerzimmer und ziehe einen durch
tschüss
Stunde nach sititzen bei Herrin
hasknecht Herr Hassknecht vielen
Dank ja gern und hknecht will nicht bis
zum 1 April mit Kiffen warten so meine
Damen und Herren spüren Sie das
eigentlich auch ein frischer Wind weht
durch die deutsche Parteienlandschaft
denn das Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht kurz
BSW startet jetzt richtig durch mit
seinem Gründungsparteitag in Berlin
letztes Wochenende und was ich da ja
besonders sympathisch fand sie stehen
zum Personenkult wirklich ja im Grunde
war das kein Parteitag sondern eine Art
Krönungsmesse ja eine Krönungsmesse mit
SAR und lafo in der der Rolle der
deutschen Royals so was wollen die mit
ihrer neuen Partei für jeden etwas
weniger Gendern mehr Umverteilung und
einen respektvolleren Ton in der Politik
sehr gut die Politik und auch das
debattenklima in unserem Land sind roh
geworden und wir werden auch nur
erfolgreich sein wenn wir Toleranz und
Respekt nicht nur in der Gesellschaft
einfordern ein paar Sekunden später das
Trio Infernale aus Habig berburg und
Lindner und grünen Moralapostel
verwöhnte Jungpolitiker Marie Agnes
Strack reheinmetall dümmste Regierung
Europas ah ja gut sie fordert mehr
Respekt außer für die bekackte Ampel ja
oder so ähnlich ihre Partei will sich
vor allem heißt es um die normalen
arbeitenden Menschen kümmern hier der
dazu passende erste offizielle parteis
Spot von uns im hinteren Teil eventuell
minimal
ert ich schaff seit 30 Jahren aber wenn
ich mal meine Rente ausrechne wie
soll wieso hängen die Bildungschancen
bei uns immer noch vom Geldbeutel der
Eltern ab das geht gar nicht ich bin 80
Jahre alt und will eigentlich nur noch
meine Ruhe und jetzt zwingt mich meine
Frau bei ihrer komischen Partei
mitzumachen bitte helfen sie mir
die Partei für alle denen keiner mehr
zuhört wir müssen einander wieder mehr
zuhören ja wir sahen Oscar la fontain
als der fast hundertjährige der aus der
Versenkung stieg und in die Partei
seiner Frau eintrat tatsächlich
tatsächlich wurde Oscars Rede auf dem
Parteitag am meisten gefeiert er war der
heimliche Star des Parteitags und das
ist kein Wunder überlegen Sie mal mit
SPD VSG PDS und Linkspartei hat der Mann
ja im Alleingang schon vier Parteien
komplett
zerstört so tatsache ist aber das BSW
ist weder nationalistisch noch
demokratiefeindlich und das ist ja
heutzutage nicht mehr selbstverständlich
aber natürlich lauern auf dem Weg zur
Volkspartei auch gewisse Gefahren wir
müssen natürlich aufpassen dass wir
nicht in die Falle tappen in die junge
neue Parteien oft tappen dass sie eben
Menschen auch aufnehmen manchmal die
auch schon durch fünf Parteien durch
gezogen sind
hallo hallo zurück ja aber stimmt
natürlich was sie da sagt jede neue
Partei ist in den ersten Monaten erstmal
so ein spinnermagnet ne deswegen hat das
BSW übrigens auch nur 450 Mitglieder
reingelassen erstmal alle weiteren
durchlaufen jetzt eine bewährungsperiode
also letztlich einen Idiotentest ne
besser ist das so das außenpolitische
Konzept von denen lässt sich tatsächlich
in einem Satz zusammenfassen mehr Moskau
Wagen also für den Frieden also
eigentlich für endlich wieder billige
Energie aus Russland aber das klingt
halt so egoistisch die Ukraine soll
endlich aufgeben damit Ruhe ist und der
Gaspreis sinkt müssen die dann auch mal
einsehen die Ukrainer nicht immer nur an
sich denken hier Methode Wagenknecht
irgendwas droppen und ganz schnell
weiterlabern bevor der Faktencheck kommt
also dass wir Öl jetzt nicht mehr direkt
aus Russland sondern über den Umweg von
Indien kaufen verteuert alles ne also es
gibt eine ganze Reihe von Dingen das
könen Sie nicht sag aber ich will ein
Punkt will ich aber auch noch sofort
aber ich will es nur in Kontext setzen
2,4% ungefähr der
Ölimporte Deutschlands kommen aus Indien
also es ist nicht so dass wir sozag das
ist ein Beispiel es ist ja es ist ja nur
ein Beispiel ne ich könnte mir noch ganz
andere Zahlen ausdenken ist kein Problem
in wagenknechts Europa Programm wird
Europa übrigens als Zitat vasal der USA
bezeichnet was ganz ulkig ist denn genau
die Formulierung hat neulich Maximilian
Krah AFD Spitzenkandidat für Europa in
seinem neuen Buch benutzt
Zufall ich meine jetzt mal
ernsthaft jetzt mal ernsthaft Kinder bei
der AFD abschreiben wie tief kann man
denn noch sinken im internen Programm
Entwurf der wagenknechtpartei für die
Europawahl findet sich etwa die typische
FDP Idee Technologie offen zu sein statt
ein Verbrenner
auszufordern also Kinder jetzt mal
ernsthaft bei der FDP schreiben wie tief
kann man denn noch sinken ne ja die
Linken und das geistige Eigentum so ist
das aber hier meine absolute
Lieblingsstelle aus dem Programm da
fordert ihre neue Friedenspartei auch
mal zu bedenken Zitat dass ein Kampfjet
in einer Stunde mehr klimaschädliche
Emissionen verursacht als ein normaler
Pkw-Fahrer in 17 Jahren verstehen sie
der Ukraine durch Waffenlieferung helfen
ist Gift fürs Klima und wenn Wagenknecht
erst Kanzlerin ist ist ja nur Frage der
Zeit wird auch die Bundeswehr endlich
klimaneutral ja dann gibt's ein
Tempolimit für Kampfjets und natürlich
CO2 neutrale
Truppentransporte ist doch logisch ja im
Grunde im Grunde ist das BSW die neue
klimapartei ne gut sie wollen
Kohlekraftwerke länger betreiben sie
fordern ein Ende des europäischen CO2
Handels und ganz wichtig bei Autos soll
das Verbrenner aus zurückgenommen werden
aber e das sind alles Details hauptsache
die Sara wird weiter in jede zweite
Talkshow eingeladen am Ende ist die
Partei eh eine one woman Show hier jetzt
nicht im BSW
Fanshop du spielst lieber mit deinem
iPad weil die altparteienbi viel zu
Mainstream ist dann hol dir jetzt die
wagenknechtbbi Sari guck mal sie hat 18
unterschiedliche absolut identische
Kostüme und vor Ihrem Traumhaus baut sie
eine eigene Gaspipeline bis nach
Russland
aber das tollste die neue Sari kommt
zusammen mit Oscar dem ältesten Ken der
Welt vielleicht mischen s die deutsche
Parteienlandschaft auf vielleicht nehmen
sie der AFD was weg heute im ZF
Politbarometer 6% und immerhin es ist
mal Bewegung in
unsererenpteienlandschaft demnächst
kommt ja noch was dazu da kommt noch die
Werte Union von hans- Georg Marsen
eiwanger will bundesweit antreten
Erdogan auch also so viele so viele neue
Player die alle sagen Ampel muss weg wie
entscheidet man sich da als wütender
Verbraucher es ist schwierig wieso viele
Deutsche ist auch Martin Klemt mit der
Gesamtsituation unzufrieden ich sag dir
die Ampel will dass er bald über das
Licht ausgeht bis auch der letzte
Betrieb dicht macht und alle nur vom
Baum kacken wie Mittelalter alles für
den Gott des Klimas h mir überhaupt
zu ja ich bin auch nicht gerade happy
mit unserer Regierung aber bei ihm ist
die Ampel wirklich auch Schuld an allem
früher vor derampel das S die
marmeladendeckel viel viel
lockerer geht
nicht was 2 kg mehr das kommt alles von
der Ampel frustfett ich verstehe das
nicht ich kann do sonst immer ich habe
halt kurz an die Ampel gedacht nicht
schlimm doch
hab zum Glück haben chronisch wütende
Menschen heute die Wahl zwischen vielen
neuen wutparteien ach der Maßen also ich
weiß nicht gegen Migration ja gut und
schön aber der hat so eine wahnsinnig
kleine Brille auf ich
ganz ich mag ja seine Wut aber was genau
redet er ist das überhaupt sie ist schon
sehr eitel kann das sein bündnissara
Wagenknecht ich habe das Gefühl es geht
nur um sie und nicht um mich weißt du
was am besten du gründest deine eigene
Partei dann wirst du Kanzler und alle
müssen exakt das machen was Du gerade
willst warte mal ja meine Damen und
Herren herzlich willkommen
zur Gründung der BMK der Bewegung Martin
klemtno schön dass sie so zahlreich
erschienen
sind unser Motto lautet frag nicht was
du für dein Land tun kannst sondern frag
dich was du für Martin Klem n tun
kannst mach jetzt mit bei der Aktion
viel mehr Parteien für Deutschland es
könnten 84 Millionen sein das ist jetzt
wirklich
albern so
Aufnahme hallo dies ist die automatische
endcard von Oliver Welke und der
heuteh leider ist das Video schon vorbei
ihr könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsst ihr jetzt
für immer reichen